[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de retrouver
cet après midi sur public sénat
poursuivre les travaux des sénateurs on
va parler de la lutte contre la
radicalisation puisque la commission d'
enquête du sénat a auditionné ce matin
zineb el rhazoui journaliste essayiste
qui milite depuis des années contre
l'islam radical et elle évoque notamment
la place croissante de l'organisation
des frères musulmans dans la société
française je vous laisse écouter son
audition en france on a coutume
maintenant de diviser l'islam radical
l'islamisme en 2de deux entités qu'on
distingue l'une de l'autre pas toujours
à raison d'ailleurs
le salafisme et le free sme je
souhaiterais parler d'aider des frères
musulmans en tant que confrérie en tant
qu'idéologie et aussi en tant qu
organisation associative très structuré
en france pour la raison suivante c'est
que je ne crains pas de dire qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui aux portes du pouvoir en
france et je vais expliquer pourquoi je
je je ne craint pas d'affirmer une chose
pareille d'abord les frères musulmans un
simple rappel c'est une confrérie née en
egypte à la fin des années 20 qui a été
fondée par un instituteur qui s'appelait
hassan al banna qui était le grand-père
maternel donc de tariq ramadan que l'on
connaît ici en france hassan al banna
quand il a créé cette confrérie il a il
a prôné une idéologie totalitaire dans
le sens où elle recouvre l ensemble des
espaces de la société la vie familiale
la vie privée l'enseignement
l'administration la politique
évidemment le rapport à l'étranger etc
il faut rappeler que cette idéologie est
une idéologie donc des années 30
qui était fille de son temps et par
ailleurs hassan al banna le fondateur de
la confrérie des frères musulmans était
un admirateur de régime nazi il a
d'ailleurs ses adeptes par la suite ont
pour certains entretenu des liens avérés
établi avec le avec les le nazisme par
exemple les mêmes le moufti à la haine
et de jérusalem qui était aussi un
membre de la confrérie avait rendu
s'était rendu en allemagne nazie pour
une visite officielle et avait même
fonder une division ss qui appelait les
ans a roulé en charge je ne sais pas si
je le prononce correctement qui était un
régiment il me semble d'albanais tout ça
est simplement un rappel ce qu'il est
important de dire c'est que cette
confrérie des frères musulmans
on retrouve son oeuvre néfaste à peu
près partout dans le monde
ça y'est de route qui a été l'idéologue
principal qui a pris repris le flambeau
de la confrérie après le décès de hassan
el banna
il a été l'un des principaux
inspirateurs de d'al qaïda la révolution
islamique en iran aussi porte bien que
l'iran soit chiite et non sunnites mais
elle porte aussi empreinte de la
confrérie des frères musulmans puisqu'il
y avait eu des déplacements deux frères
musulmans dans la société iranienne
bien avant la révolution iranienne qui
avait qui s'appelait d'ailleurs les à
roanne muslim in les frères musulmans et
qui ont contribué à l'islamisation
profonde rapide à l'échelle de
l'histoire lente qui prend des années
des décennies peut-être mais qui a
participé à changer le visage de la
société iranienne
comment est-ce que cette confrérie est
arrivé en europe et en france
particulièrement la france est l'un des
premiers pays où cette confrérie va
s'implanter en europe jeu
eo simplement lire un petit rappel donc
en france lorsque nous parlons des
frères musulmans en tant qu'organisation
nous parlons principalement de luriecq
l'union des organisations islamiques de
france donc en 1962 on hamma hammami
donna né en 1908 décédé en 2002 qui
était docteur en droit et en philosophie
originaire d'inde s'exile en france en
48 et il fonde l'association des
étudiants islamiques de france à la fin
des années soixante dix un groupe
d'étudiants d'origine tunisienne
s'établissent en france après la
répression que bourguiba avait avait
mené contre le mouvement de la tendance
islamique donc et qui est l'ancêtre du
parti tunisien mode le parti annahda qui
a pris le pouvoir en tunisie est un
parti qui adhère pleinement à la
confrérie des frères musulmans
d'ailleurs dans le bureau de la
commanderie des frères musulmans au
caire on retrouve entre autres portraits
des lustres membres de la confrérie
le portrait de rached el ghannouchi
l'ancien président tunisien
donc il était chargé j'avale là de créer
une antenne en france 7 donc ce
mouvement de la tendance islamique
intègre la imiev de mama damidot loi
crée donc ans qui est arrivé en france
en 62 et se rattache à la branche
égyptienne des frères musulmans donc là
on a un lien très très claire entre
entre l'arrivée de ces étudiants
frériste de tunisie et le rattachement
de ces structures là qui était
balbutiante en france à la branche
égyptienne des frères musulmans mais la
majorité de la ufa l'époque reste sous
l'influencé de la branche syrienne
troisième date importante 1979 les pros
égyptiens vont quitter la liesse et
fondé le groupement islamiques de france
le gf en 80 bourguiba déclenché une
forte répression donc de nombreux
sympathisants s'exile en france tunisien
encore et rejoignent le gf100 83 les
dirigeants du gf fonde avec d'autres
associations locales
l'union des organisations islamiques de
france lui relief donc les principaux
dirigeants sont des tunisiens donc ahmad
jaballah et abdallah ben mansour et le
libanais fayçal mawlawi ensuite on
arrive à une période plus contemporaines
qui parle à tous les français qui
s'intéressent au sujet de l'islamisme 89
la sphère du foulard de creil la sphère
du foulard de creil qui était en phase
d'être réglé avec le proviseur du lycée
a pris une nouvelle tournure lorsque
l'ue relief a pris contact avec les
familles de ces jeunes filles pour leur
dire il ne faut pas céder
donc c'est à ce moment là que lui au
lièvre va avoir une véritable visibilité
en france avec la sphère du foulard de
créer en 90 l'unef lui niant de l'union
des organisations islamiques en france
et c'est un détail très important
elle s'appelait l'union des
organisations islamiques en france va
devenir l'union des organisations
islamiques de france et c'est très
important parce que je voudrais
après cette introduction venir à ce
projet dont on parle qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre ce chantier qui
s'appelle l'islam de france 2/france
j'insiste là dessus parce que l'islam de
france est un concept en réalité qui
sort des tiroirs de lui
f donc en 90 on passe de l'union des
organisations islamiques en france à
l'union des organisations islamiques de
france et lui relief donc participé à la
fondation de la fédération des
organisations islamiques d'europe
fo 92 luriecq créé l'institut européen
des sciences humaines iesh de château
chinon dirigé par l'irak hier moods of
95 les marocains prennent la tête de
l'ue relief fouad alaoui acheter amis
braises chaudes et donc ils prennent le
pouvoir aux tunisiens 99
c'est l'entrée officielle de l'ue relief
pour la première fois dans le giron des
des tractations républicaine donc jean
pierre chevènement à l'époque participe
donc invitent l'ue au lièvre a participé
à la mise en place d'une instance
représentative
là je voudrais ouvrir une petite une
petite parenthèse puisque nous sommes au
sénat justement sous chevènement on a un
on a un rapport sénatorial de 2015 qui
en page 5 178 qui fait que nos 5 178
pages met à la page 87
on y lit un passage très inquiétant qui
datent de 99 donc chevènement était jean
pierre chevènement était premier
ministre ministre de l'intérieur pardon
et je lis la mention encadré ici dans le
rapport donc le ministre de l'intérieur
fait précéder la réflexion sur la
composition et la place de l'instance
représentative d'une reconnaissance
mutuelle etc
ce texte est accepté mais au prix d'un
compromis sur son contenu
la mention du droit de changer de
religion et notamment retiré à la
demande de luriecq donc en 99 il y a eu
un compromis même une compromission sur
la liberté de conscience des français
de confession musulmane à auquel lui
rieff conteste de façon très officielle
le droit de changer de religion
donc on a cette première étape cette
première reconnaissance de l'ue relief
qui comme je les dis à une filiation
très clair avec l'organisation des
frères musulmans en en 99 lorsque je
vainement les invite à participer à la
mise en place d'une instance
représentative
ensuite nous avons donc on est sous joxe
pour régler la crise du voile de creil
on a fondé un quelque chose qui
s'appelait un conseil de sages musulmans
qui ont qui avait pour mission de
contribuer à régler la crise du foulard
de créer parmi lesquels il y avait amar
lasfar amar lasfar qui est le fondateur
de l'ue au relief donc ensuite on arrive
à 2003 lorsque le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy intègre lui
relief à au cfcm conseil français du
culte musulman
en 2003 il se rend au bourget le
rassemblement des musulmans au bourget
qui est l'événement l'événement phare de
l'ue relief en france donc nicolas
sarkozy s'y rend et il me semble que
l'année d'après à ma a été a marqué une
explosion de présence au rassemblement
des musulmans du bourget je pense que le
nombre a littéralement doublé
pourquoi ai je parlé de luriecq dans
cette introduction est pourquoi je tenu
à établir sa filiation avec les frères
musulmans
c'est parce que il me semble que qu'en
france nous avons une âme compréhension
de ce que sont les frères musulmans et
de leur dangerosité
les frères musulmans sont des gens qui
bien souvent n'ont pas de différences
vestimentaires avec avec les personnes
laïques que ce sont des personnes qui
s'habille en costume qui se mettent en
cravate qui se rasent qu'ils sont moins
braqués sur les expressions visible de
l'islamisme contrairement aux salafistes
mais il faut savoir que les frères
musulmans sont du point de vue du dogme
des salafistes
ce qui les différencie des salafistes ce
n'est pas le dogme ni la foi puisqu'il
croit exactement les mêmes théoriciens
les mêmes idéologues
la seule différence est une différence
de méthode si les salafistes pour eux le
mode de vie islamique est une fin en soi
à tel point que nous avons des certaines
branches du salafisme qui qui vivent qui
préfèrent vivre en retrait de la société
puisqu'elle refuse toutes les
expressions modernes de la société les
frères musulmans eux ont la même
finalité c'est à dire la l'hégémonie de
l'islam
la suprématie de l'islam des lois
d'allah sur les lois
de la république les lois de l'état les
lois démocratiques mais ils ont une
méthode différente pour y arriver cette
méthode
elle est basée sur un travail en
profondeur de la société par
l'infiltration de toutes ces
institutions je pense que devant cette
commission
vous avez vu passer des aspects de cette
de cet entrisme là dans le sport dans
l'enseignement dans le milieu médical
etc
tout ceci nous amène à parler de du
projet que je trouve inquiétant à bien
des égards qui est le projet de l'amif
l'association musulmane pour l'islam de
france dont le titre est redondant comme
vous pouvez le constater et dans lequel
on reprend ce concept d' islam de france
pour ma part si je puis dire mon opinion
je je je pense qu'il est dangereux
d'entériner ce concept dangereux
sémantiquement et la bataille contre
l'islamisme est aussi une bataille
sémantique dans laquelle il est
important de dire les bons mots je
trouve qu'il est entérinée de qu'il est
dangereux d'entériner ce concept d'
islam de france de culte de france car
il n'y a pas de christianisme 2 france 2
judaïsme de france qu'il ne devrait pas
y avoir de l'islam de france il ya un
islam en france il ya des cultes en
france mais pas de culte de france
or le concept même d'islam de france qui
est donc repris de l'ue relief est
aujourd'hui promu par la mif
il est on le retrouve dans tout dans
toute la littérature dans tous les
écrits des membres de la de l'ue relief
et donc de la route des membres ou
sympathisants de l'uejf car il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être membre de l'ue aux
lièvres pour être adhérent à l'idéologie
des frères musulmans
on peut tout à fait être un adepte de la
pensée de de youssef qaradawi de saillé
de comptes sans être membre sur le plan
organisationnel de l'ue relief par
exemple là nous avons
farid abdelkrim qui dans son livre dit
l'islam saura français ou ne sera pas
voilà il y à il ya cette volonté de de
faire de l'islam
quelque chose de comment dire quelque
chose de profondément constitutifs de ce
qu'est l'identité française est
d'ailleurs dans ses objectifs
la mif le dit elle ne s'en cache pas la
mif affiche comme objectif je les cite
une insertion sereine de l'islam dans la
république
énorme écueil car nous pouvons
évidemment bien parlé d'insertion des
musulmans mais l'insertion de l'islam
dans la république il me semble que
qu'une telle expression en soi pose un
petit problème par rapport à la loi de
donc la mif l'association musulmane pour
l'islam de france est une initiative de
hakim el karoui qu'on qualifie de croche
du président il est essayiste il est
également les anciens banquiers et il a
dirigé deux rapports au sein de
l'institut montaigne la fabrique de
l'islamisme et enfin ces deux rapports
je tiens à le dire sont particulièrement
bien fait bien fouillé très très bien
fait il
ils font le tour de la question de façon
très savante très étayé mais on peut
reprocher aux études faites par monsieur
el karoui au sein de l'institut
montaigne de focaliser le danger de
l'islamisme uniquement sur le salafisme
est d'ailleurs le projet que monsieur el
karoui présentera à l'issue de ces deux
rapports donc le projet de l'amif est un
projet auquel on peut reprocher sans
craindre la contradiction d'être à une
une émanation de l'unef je m'explique la
mif est l'un des trois projets qui ont
été présentés par les représentants de
d2 du culte musulman en france à
l'exécutif il y a eu la mif
l'association 2
pour l'islam de france le cfcm également
a fait une proposition et on a aussi vu
la plateforme les musulmans elles
pointent eux
point s musulmans de marwan muhammad
dans laquelle on retrouve l'inénarrable
hasan imam hassan iquioussen et d'autres
personnes pourquoi je préfère pour voir
pourquoi je me concentre sur la mif ce
n'est pas parce que je trouve les les
deux autres propositions meilleure mais
c'est parce que il
il est à craindre que ce soit le projet
de la mif qui remporte les faveurs de
l'exécutif
étant donné les moyens de communication
dont jouit la mif l'énorme coup de com
qui qui jusqu'à récemment d'ailleurs
dans un documentaire consacré à l'islam
en france qui a été diffusé sur la
chaîne arte on a eu de nombreux membres
du projet de la mif qui se sont exprimés
sans dire leur nom et d'ailleurs ça
c'est une caractéristique essentielle de
la confrérie des frères musulmans
c'est que ce sont des gens qui ne disent
pas leur nom ils peuvent arriver
jusqu'aux marches du pouvoir sans dire
leur nom c'est ainsi que ça s'est passé
par exemple en tunisie quand bien même
c'était un secret de polichinelle
camarda c'était des frères musulmans
mais ce n'est jamais ainsi qu'il se
présente la leaf donc la mif dans son
dans son staff global compte jusqu'à une
vingtaine de membres ou de proches ou de
sympathisants de luriecq l'amif comporte
deux branches il y à une amie loi de
donc c'est le volet culturel de
l'association et il y à une amie froid
de 1901
c'est le chapitre culturel l'amif 1905
est présidée par
tareq oubrou imam de bordeaux membres de
l'ue relief pendant 35 ans il les a
quittés en mai 2018 donc très récemment
quasiment au moment où le projet de
l'amif été mis en route donc et
d'ailleurs il déclare lui même ce
hoobrouck ce n'est pas une rupture avec
lui hier qu'il qualifie de famille pour
lui c'est sa famille donc
et monsieur regroupent par ailleurs
s'est réclamé à de nombreuses reprises
de la pensée de hassan al-banna qui pour
lui est éteint et 1 voilà est un
philosophe ou je ne sais pas comment ils
le font ils préfèrent oui il préfère
parler de la mystique de rasamimanana
qui en réalité n'a vait pas que là que
la mystique qui n'avaient pas prôner des
choses très mystique
le numéro deux le vice président de
l'amif 2 905
c'est l'imam
moi-même bajra fils secrétaire du
conseil théologique des musulmans de
france
car je dois rappeler que lui on y est a
été rebaptisé pour des raisons
politiques et de communication musulmans
de france en 2010 est donc c'est une
très belle opération de com
d'ailleurs le l'appellation frères
musulmans elle même prête à énormément
de de confusion car finalement la
fraternité c'est quelque chose qu'on
aime tous surtout ici en france met la
fraternité en islam n'est pas du tout la
fraternité républicaine à laquelle nous
croyons tous ici présents et le fait de
se rebaptiser musulmans de france c'est
encore une rupture c'est encore une
mystification et une rupture en terme de
communication avec le avec lui au relief
donc mohamed magera fille lui il est il
est secrétaire du conseil théologique
des musulmans de france donc c'est
l'instance théologique de l'unef est par
ailleurs sur son site il
ils se réclament aussi de hilla il se
réclame de carrément de youssef qaradawi
youssef qaradawi qui est le plus grand
idéologue aujourd'hui des frères
musulmans qui vit au qatar et qui est
interdit de séjour en france depuis 2012
youssef qaradawi on lui il doit par
exemple des déclarations antisémites
disant que bon hein
hitler avait peut-être exagéré un peu
mais ma foi c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire avec les juifs
on a donc la trésorière serre y est à
midi je fasse maintenant à d'autres
membres éminents de la mif
on a abdelghani ben ali qui enseigne en
106 l'amicale us h saint denis qui est
un organisme de formation de l'ue relief
on a hâte des lacs nabawi anciens
délégués de l'île aux lièvres pour le
grand test président lui au lief en
alsace aumônier militaire aumônier
hospitalier farid abdelkrim aussi les
membres de la miss farid abdelkrim est
ancien président des jeunes musulmans de
france section jeunesse
de l'uejf on a à z inga six imams relief
de la mosquée de villeurbanne et c'est
pour ne citer qu'eux jeudi qu' en tout
on a une vingtaine de membres qui
composent la mif qui sont membres
directs ou sympathisants ou proches de
l'ue y f sur le chapitre culturel qui
est présidée par hakim el karoui donc là
nous parlons de l'amif loi de 1901 donc
sont dix présidences et hosni mathide
trésorier abdel nos ardennes nord celle
là oui l'amour trouvons quoi nous
retrouvons des personnes des
spécialistes en finance islamique
évidemment nous retrouvons des
spécialistes en communication des
conseillers politiques des personnes qui
agissent dans le secteur hospitalier
des personnes qui sont proches du milieu
du sport donc nous nous retrouvons tous
les aspects de la société qui permettent
donc à la mif de couvrir absolument tous
les aspects de la société française donc
par exemple la mif dans ses projets
puisque la mif est aussi une histoire de
dessous une histoire d'argent dans les
projets de la mif qui pour l'instant ont
été mis en stand by pour des difficultés
de mise en place par exemple il y avait
cette idée d'une taxe halal qui
financerait le culte il y a aussi cette
idée de deux certifie de certificats
d'instance d'une instance qui certifie
les instances qui certifie le halal
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous avons deux
mosquées en france qui font la
certification halal est bien la mif
propose de certifier les organismes
certificateurs est effectivement de
prélever une taxe de ce1 organisme qui
certifie aussi les agences de voyages
qui vont organiser le hadj le pèlerinage
en arabie saoudite
et donc tout cet argent récolté il
servira selon la mif à la formation des
imams
donc si puisque nous avons des
abdelghani abdelghani ben ali qui est
membre de la mif
il est enseigné en sciences islamiques a
lieu et sache donc l'institut de
formation des frères musulmans
nous pouvons craindre une une
augmentation exponentielle de formation
d'imams à la théorie donc ce à la sauce
des frères musulmans la mif propose
aussi que cet argent récolté par sur le
h sur le halal sur les donations sur ses
nombreux projets caritatifs puisque on
sait que la mif et proches par exemple
du secours islamique
il suffit d'aller sur le le site du
secours islamique pour se rendre compte
par exemple que le secours islamique
propose en langue française sur son site
le secours islamique français il propose
aux musulmans de se débarrasser de
l'argent des intérêts bancaires puisque
les intérêts bancaires sont interdits
donc c'est de l'argent ici donc se
débarrasser de l'argent des intérêts
bancaires en le donnant à la charité
charité évidemment tout islamique et
communautaire donc cet argent qui sera
récoltée par la mif par sept différents
biais servira à la fois à la formation
des imams
mais aussi selon la mif la lutte contre
la radicalisation et et ça c'est dans la
même phrase puisque la lutte contre la
radicalisation selon les gens de l'amif
va de pair avec la lutte alors ils
disent pas islamophobie 1
mais la lutte contre les discriminations
évidemment les discriminations visant
uniquement les musulmans car cette
doctrine aujourd'hui elle est également
répandu dans ces milieux-là d'abord tous
ces organismes qui font de la
radicalisation de la déradicalisation
n'allons pas bien loin parlons du caduc
a pris à bordeaux qui est gérée par
tariq oubrou président de l'amif c'est
une des radicalisations qui se fait de
la façon suivante on dit aux gens ça
c'est le mauvais islam
nous allons vous donner le bon islam
donc on eu des radicalistes pas par le
doute par la raison critique par
l'universalisme mais pas encore plus
d'islam donc et la doctrine de ces
gens-là consiste à dire la
radicalisation par ailleurs qui est un
mot que je n'aime pas
car c'est un mot qui aseptise le débat
moi je préfère parler d'islamisation la
radicalisation selon eux serait le fruit
logique de l'islamophobie donc des
discriminations elles seraient en gros
de la faute de la société française ce
qui est une thèse que je combats de
toutes mes forces
car je pense que c'est un phénomène
international et global qui est inhérent
à la tournure philosophique même que vit
la religion musulmane est d'ailleurs les
problèmes de radicalisation sont quelque
chose que l'on rencontre des philippines
jusqu'au nigeria en passant par tous les
pays où il ya une forte présence de
l'islam
donc il ne me semble pas qu'il faille en
chercher les raisons dans ce que nous
sommes nous en tant que société
française je pense avoir fait le tour
rapidement de de l'amif il
il reste beaucoup de choses à dire
beaucoup de subtilité beaucoup de
détails je j'ai des documents que je
tiens à la disposition de tous tous ceux
qui souhaitent aller plus loin mais
aujourd'hui à pointer la mif comme
instance représentative de ce qu'ils
appellent l'islam de france va générer
une quelque chose non gérables
nous sommes aujourd'hui déjà en france
en train de patauger dans ces problèmes
nous n'arrivons plus à gérer le la
montée de l'islamisme de toutes parts or
m des frères musulmans des gens qui sont
frériste qui applique à la lettre la
théorie de youssef al qaradawi il faut
savoir que youssef al qaradawi le grand
idéologue des frères musulmans
il a mis en place une charia
spécialement dédié aux minorités
musulmanes en occident
ça s'appelle fécales aliette al muslim a
fait rare donc la charia des minorités
musulmanes en occident et aujourd'hui ce
que lorsqu'on lit les écrits de monsieur
tarek oubrou président de l'amif ils
sont le la traduction de cette charia là
qu'est ce que dit cette charia elle dit
un filtre on forme des élites ne
braquent ont pas forcément sur le voile
les choses vont se faire par étapes
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que il y à une
opposition entre une opposition parfois
entre les frères musulmans et les
salafistes
c'est que les frères musulmans 12 ces
abrutis de salafistes ils nous mettent
les bâtons dans les roues
ils sont braqués sur leur tenue sur leur
mode de vie sur le halal alors qu'en
réalité ce n'est pas ça qui est le plus
important le plus important c'est de
marquer de l'empreinte de l'islam toutes
les institutions
2 les infiltrés de former des élites qui
place
le l'idéologie de l'islamisme aux deux
au dessus des valeurs républicaines
tout en intégrant ces valeurs
républicaines et monsieur roux brou
aujourd'hui a évidemment compris qu'il
fallait avoir un discours irréprochable
républicain mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que l'objectif est toujours de
mettre plus d'islam dans la république
je voudrais finir en lisant une citation
de monsieur au bout dans le poids qui
date du 13 juin 2019 il dit si les
musulmans de france veulent s'intégrer
il faut donc qu'ils adoptent le
comportement de prudence de l'animal qui
quand il pénètre un univers qu'il ne
connaît pas minimise ses mouvements et
réduit prudemment sa visibilité pour ne
pas s'exposer c'est un bon résumé de ce
qu'est la charia des minorités
musulmanes en occident
donc je pense que ça serait une très
grosse erreur historique de livrer là
les français de confession musulmane clé
en main à la mif ça serait ça serait les
mettre dans un piège puisque 7 7
cette instance théologique se prennent
que veut créer la mif qui en réalité
s'apparente à une forme de clergé de
clergé adoubé par la république pourra
également émettre des fatwas et pour et
comptera pour autorité suprême en
matière de religion
mon conseil à moi personnellement à aux
différents représentants de l'état
français
c'est de dire que toute tentative
d'organisation de l'islam par le haut
débouchera fatalement sur la pointe
mende est plus militant parmi les
musulmans
donc si on craint l'islam politique
qu'est ce que l'islam politique
finalement que si ce n'est que de parler
en son nom et que de vouloir qu'il
existe en tant que tel au sein des
instances républicaines ça débouchera
fatalement justement sur une sur une une
instance qui bénéficiera de
d'une reconnaissance républicaine et qui
ne prône pas qu'il ne prendre pas des
valeurs tout à fait républicaine mon
conseil est donc de laisser la pluralité
de l'islam s'exprimer et de laisser les
initiatives germé dans la division par
ailleurs tous ses représentants
autoproclamés de l'islam qui ne
représentent qu'eux mêmes car rappelons
quand même qu'en république
nous ne sommes représentés que par nos
élus et que personne n'a élus ces gens
là donc tous ces représentants
autoproclamés de l'islam qui veulent
être qu'ils veulent une reconnaissance
républicaine qui veulent des légions
d'honneur qui veulent être reçus au
sénat qui veulent être reçus à l'elysée
que leurs demandes tout en contrepartie
rien est ce qu'on leur a demandé de
faire un effort sur la question de la
post asie je rappelle quand même que les
apostats de l'islam sont une minorité à
une minorité
tant qu'ils ne peuvent pas le dire mais
en tout cas sont une partie de la
population dont le droit à la vie est
remis en question tous les jours au vu
et au su de tout le monde
et d'ailleurs même la mention de droit
de changer de religion a été retirée
d'un rapport sénatorial comme je les dis
précédemment 99
qu'est ce qu'on demande à ses
représentants autoproclamés en termes
d'égalité homme femme
qu'est ce qu'on leur demande sur les
questions de l'antisémitisme de
l'antichristianisme également rien du
tout donc moi je pense que la république
doit rester en position de force qu'elle
doit observer la loi de 1905 les le
culte musulman est inculte libre
d'exercice en france comme le lui permet
la loi de 1905
mais si je puis me permettre je je je je
pense qu'il faut préserver la pluralité
car c'est dans la pluralité que
germeront véritablement les initiatives
républicaine et qu'il faut écarter toute
velléité d'organiser l'islam par le haut
car cela risque de déboucher sur quelque
chose de concorde à terre voire sur sur
un ersatz de religion d'état
merci beaucoup madame el rhazoui de
votre exposé très clair très détaillée
je vais demander maintenant mes
collègues si certains d'entre eux ont
des questions de se manifester pour que
nous puissions n'est notée par ordre
j'aurai une première question je
passerai la parole à madame la reporter
nous avons reçu mardi dernier
hugo michon je ne sais pas si vous avez
pris connaissance alors de sa thèse non
qu'est ce qu'il semble qu'elle soit si
vous embarquent au pendant plusieurs
années mais de son livre et des
différentes expressions qu'il a pu avoir
l'occasion de cette sortie de livres lui
parle depuis des années
lui dit que nous n'aurons pas une
seconde chance il parle depuis des
années de deuil naïveté de la recherche
de l'université et du manque peut-être
de recherche universitaire d'ailleurs en
ce sens de la pudeur politique de
l'ignorance de la société civile mais
exprime effectivement le souhait d'une
poignée de personnes d'organiser une
infiltration soit pacifique
institutionnels comme vous avez pu le
décrire
pour tarek au groupe par exemple ou de
façon plus violente par une
manifestation terroristes dont vous avez
commencé à donner quelques conseils des
solutions lui aussi ex qui esquissent
des solutions est ce que vous pourriez
être plus précise dans ses solutions
vous le décrivez je pense que le
problème n'est pas la loi de 1905 mais
plutôt la loi de 1901 il y a
effectivement la formation des imams
peut être l'interdiction de certaines
formations
donc voilà je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez aller peut-être un peu plus
loin dans ses conseils ou ses
recommandations merci merci alors
d'abord la loi de 1905 ne pêche que par
son manque d'application son absence
d'applications dans certains cas lorsque
lorsque le l'exécutif avait émis la
volonté de réformer la loi de 1905 nous
avons tout le mouvement laïque français
s'y est opposé à son corps défendant et
nous disions mais cette loi n'a pas
besoin d'être réformées et on a besoin
du courage politique de la piquer il ya
des articles de la loi de 1905
d'ailleurs même maintenant l'article le
premier et le second qui ont valeur
constitutionnelle ne ne le sont pas
forcément mais alors je ne parle pas des
quarante deux autres l'article 26 par
exemple qui dit qu'aucun lieu de culte
ne peut servir à héberger un discours
politique c'est un article qui
allègrement violé en france sans que
personne ne s'en émeuve
ou au moins quelques voilà quelques
quelques citoyens quelques
journaliste sénateurs mais qui crie qui
crient dans un désert il est fondamental
fondamentale en france d'assainir le
champ sémantique de sortir de la
sémantique qui nous a été imposée par
les islamistes cc il me semble le
premier pas que nous devons franchir
nous devons voir et dire ce que nous
voyons plutôt que de dire ce que nous
pensons qu'il est de bon ton de dire ce
débat-là en france est prise en otage
depuis des décennies maintenant du
politiquement correct qui fait
l'amalgamé entre ces questions là et des
questions telles que le racisme etc etc
ça nous amène au à la notion
d'islamophobie
cette motion il faut la combattre par
des moyens plus renforcée que la simple
dénonciation
car en réalité d'abord c'est une c'est
une imposture intellectuelle
deuxièmement l'islamophobie n'est rien
d'autre que le revers de la médaille du
blasphème dans les pays où l'islam a le
pouvoir coercitif
il n'existe pas d'islamophobie il existe
le blasphème
lorsqu'on critique l'islam on est mis en
prison sous été lapidée et c'est ici en
france on est accusé d'islamophobie
c'est une façon de finalement de kylie à
un délit de blasphème qui ne dit pas son
nom
deuxièmement sur le sur la question
sémantique uniquement la la la l'anac de
la déradicalisation je pense que nous
avons là dessus un énorme un gros
problème de doctrine en france qui que
l'on peut diviser
d'abord le premier écueil doctrinal
c'est de penser que le problème que pose
l'islam isme c'est uniquement le
terrorisme en réalité le terrorisme n'en
est que l'expression
la plus violente car c'est une
expression criminels mais le terrorisme
n'est pas une finalité en soi pour
l'islamisme
le terrorisme c'est un moyen comme il en
existe d'autres comme l'entrisme
politique comme le le prosélytisme comme
la charité comme il existe un tas de
moyens pour islamiser la société en
profondeur et le terrorisme en étant
donc en france le ce qui a été fait
jusqu'ici c'est de dire aux musulmans
intégristes qui pose problème
s'il vous plaît les gars ne vous fait
pas exploser pas de terrorisme mais
restez dans votre idéologie finalement
l'islam n'est-il pas une religion de
paix d'amour comme on a coutume de dire
bon il faut d'abord savoir qu en
théologie la paix n'est pas que l'on
entend ici en théologie la paix c'est ce
qui plaît à dieu
or nous les hommes ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas ainsi qu'on qualifie la paix donc
laissez tamack de la déradicalisation
qui consiste à considérer des criminels
de masse comme des personnes malades ou
fragiles ou comme des victimes qu'il
faut prendre en charge est quelque chose
qui ne nous mènera nulle part il faudra
sortir de cette de cette doctrine faire
marche arrière
c'est d'autant plus compliqué maintenant
que la déradicalisation est devenu un
juteux marché auquel personne ne demande
des explications
personnellement je suis très curieuse
d'entendre les l'étonnant de la
déradicalisation dans ce pays et de leur
demander quelle est votre méthode
scientifique
comment comment ça fonctionne
scientifiquement
quelle est la proche est elle si kia
trick était le scientifique
de quoi s'agit-il exactement et que
lorsqu'on apprend qu'en plus c'est
facultatif c'est le pompon donc moi je
pense que la déradicalisation il n'y a
qu'une seule et unique façon de la faire
c'est de libérer la raison critique de
défendre la liberté de parole car
finalement pour que l'on sorte de
l'endoctrinement islamistes il faut qu'à
un moment il faut qu'on goûte
il faut qu'il y ait le doute ceux qui
ont pu sortir de ça ils sont rares mais
j'en connais à titre personnel 2 je
connais deux anciens salafistes qui ce
sont des radicalités pas en france
d'ailleurs un au maroc et un en arabie
saoudite
ils ce sont des radicaliser en prison
par la lecture des auteurs qui des
auteurs qui ont quitté critique sur la
religion musulmane donc la seule façon
de des radicalités c'est de libérer la
critique la parole sur la sur l'islam et
c'est de promouvoir la laïcité au plutôt
que de mettre de l'argent dans des
associations qui font faire des brioches
ou des matches de basket à des à des
criminels de masse je préfère que l'on
promeut des associations qui font de la
pédagogie sur la laïcité qui est
aujourd'hui très peu connu l'autre
recommandation que je pourrai que je
pourrais faire c'est c2c de cibler les
zones où il y à une urgence ce n'est pas
pour rien que mes anciens collègues de
charlie hebdo ont été assassinés car
c'était le seul phare du blasphème dans
ce pays d'ailleurs peut-être
probablement dans le monde et se fa a
été abattu en france ce qui est un drame
une perte inestimable pour toute
l'humanité
il est urgent urgent de rétablir le
droit au blasphème à l'irrévérence et la
critique de l'islam et ça peut ça doit
être fait de la part de l'état en
préservant le droit de le faire en
veillant à ce que ceux qui le font
puissent nos faire en france mais aussi
en promouvant les les structures qui
explique pourquoi il est nécessaire de
faire pourquoi la la cette frontière
r du blasphème et ceux qui dessinent la
frontière entre un état civilisé et un
état barbare il est fondamental de
rétablir sa de protéger les personnes de
promouvoir et d'aider les personnes qui
ont une parole critique à l'islam car
l'état ne peut pas dire aux musulmans de
changer d'avis mais ces personnes-là de
la société civile peuvent le faire je
vous remercie madame la reporter d'abord
merci zineb pour ses propos d'une
franchise est d'une clarté
extraordinaire parce que je sais que
cette parole nous est en tout cas moi à
titre personnel ça me fait du bien de
l'entendre parce que effectivement comme
beaucoup qui prend un autre sens
tellement je suis avant tout une
républicaine et ce combat pour la
république il est nécessaire aujourd'hui
et de manière urgente comme vous l'avez
exprimer
c'est vrai que nous avons des quartiers
aujourd'hui qui sont dans l'enfermement
intellectuel et religieux qui peuvent
poser problème aujourd'hui et demain
ce camp des enfants dans des quartiers
sont assignés à résidence au nom d'une
religion
on peut imaginer ce qu'ils deviendront
quand ils auront 15 20 et 30 ans et
c'est ce combat là que nous devons mener
la franchise de vos propos fait du bien
donc 1000mercis moi justement je voulais
revenir sur le côté associatif qui fait
dans le cas de la déradicalisation des
gâteaux et des matchs de foot
moi ya quelque chose qui m'inquiète
davantage pour l'avenir bon je partage
complètement vos propos sur la mif et
l'amif m'inquiète beaucoup
mais récemment on a vu dans la presse
que le gouvernement commence un peu à
s'inquiéter sur l'autoritarisme
il serait temps et je ne critique pas
simplement le gouvernement actuel parce
que ça date pas d'hier ont fait les
grands noms composés choses et j'ai lu
quelques articles récemment d'abord qui
dit qu'il ya 150 quartiers qui sont
quand même dans cette difficulté du
communautarisme et de l'islamisme
150 c'est pas rien et je lisais encore
hier un article qui m'interroge et c'est
là dessus que je vais vous donner votre
avis houas ministre est allé dans des
quartiers en disant que pour pouvoir
lutter contre le communautarisme on
allait s'appuyer sur les associations
tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire à mon
sens parce que dans les quartiers déjà
infiltrée par les frères musulmans ou
par l'islam radical dans l'islamisme
c'est parce que des associations ils y
ont participé donc je vais savoir mois
pour moi c'est le rôle de l'état et de
riendeau
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sade se
dire que pour lutter contre le
communautarisme on va s'appuyer sur des
associations de quartier je voudrais
avoir votre avis là-dessus
alors merci pour cette question à
laquelle d'ailleurs la réponse complète
à la réponse à la question précédente
d'abord il faut savoir que l'islam en
france est structuré sous forme
associative des centaines d'associations
l'amif c'est c'est un conglomérat
d'associations la plateforme les
musulmans c'est un conglomérat
d'associations et le cfcm également sans
parler des associations qui qui sont
purement cultuelle mais qui se cache
sous différentes formes et qui
n'adhèrent à aucune de ces trois
plateformes et sans parler des
associations qui ne sont pas des
associations cultuelles mais qui sont
infiltrés qui servent concrètement deux
plateformes ou d'appui associatif à
cette idéologie
ça peut être des associations sportives
par exemple toutes sortes d'associations
je pense qu'il y à une urgence extrême
c'est de faire un grand nettoyage dans
les subventions et c'est d'ailleurs
c'est la responsabilité que porte les
élus français est colossal parce que
c'est juste ce sont eux qui ont qui
possède les leviers sur cette manne
distribuée au champ associatif et il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui lorsque nous en
tant que mouvement laïc arrivons à
établir qu'un et lui verse à verser une
subvention de tellement mon temps à une
association anti républicaine qui
promeut le le voilement des petites
fillettes qui promeut les horaires non
mixtes dans des piscines une association
sportive qui en réalité est un est un
lieu de rencontre de fichier s qui
viennent s'entraîner à la boxe sortes de
choses est qui et qui bénéficient de
subventions
il ne se passe rien il y à une impunité
pour ces élus là acquis le prince
de reddition des comptes n'est plus
demandé je pense qu'il y a véritablement
quelque chose à faire là dessus c'est à
dire le principe sacro-saint principe
démocratique de la reddition des comptes
aux élus qui en sachant ce qu'ils font
bien qu'ayant été prévenus de la nature
de l'association à laquelle y verse des
subventions le font quand même et c'est
un écueil majeur aussi que la république
est cédé le terrain aux associations
c'est quelque chose ne va pas remettre
en question l'utilité de tissu
associatif de la société civile mais en
aucun cas les associations ne peuvent se
substituer à l'état dans des secteurs
aussi vitaux
donc je trouve que c'est un écueil
majeur les associations par ailleurs
sont des initiatives auto auto auto
organisés qui ne sont pas soumises ni au
principe des élections ni au principe de
la reddition des comptes ou non de façon
très sommaire donc je trouve qu'il est
extrêmement dangereux
en effet de céder ce terrain-là aux
associations moi je vais revenir sur le
fond parce que cette loi 1905 et je
voulais revenir sur les propos notre
collègue il faut juste pas savoir que
nous sommes tous autour de la table pour
mon avis alors il ya des plus jeunes je
sais mais nous avons été construit avec
cette relativité qui faisait partie de
notre quotidien et qui ne posait aucun
problème aucun pourquoi nous reparlons
la laïcité c'est parce que depuis dix
ans l'islam veut la remettre en cause
il faut juste avoir l'honnêteté de dire
ça moi j'ai été élevé sont tous les
matins bras mes parents me rappelle que
nous indien est laïque
ça faisait partie notre quotidien faut
avoir l'honnêteté de dire aujourd'hui
que pourquoi nous en parlons c'est parce
qu'il y à cet entrisme de l'islam
radical qui veut la remettre en cause et
nous devons résister à ça nous devons
résister à ça parce que c'est
l'abattement des islamistes la laïcité
c'est une réalité est que c'est la
chance de tous les enfants de ce pays de
vivre avec des règles communes et la
laïcité en fait partie je pense que
c'est ce que ce que nous partageons
ensemble et qu' il ne nous appartient
pas de remettre en cause ce que nous
avons difficilement construit parce que
cela a été six
mais difficilement mais en tout cas
actée dans ce pacte républicain
aujourd'hui et je voudrais juste revenir
là dessus parce que dans certaines
associations
vous avez parlé des financements tout à
l'heure est ce qu'une solution ne
serait-elle ne serrez pas d'imposer une
charte de laïcité et du respect de la
laïcité à toutes les associations qui
reçoit des financements publics
est-ce que déjà ce petit levier c'est
petit ce petit bien que des
collectivités ont déjà fait que des
régions déjà fait ça serait aussi pas
moyen de rappeler que tout financement
public est liée au respect de la laïcité
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je suis
pourtant excusez moi je pense que ça
serait souhaitable
malheureusement j'ai assez peu confiance
lorsque façon lorsque je fais le constat
que la laïcité n'est même plus appliqué
comme elle devrait l'être dans le
service public
dans les écoles les hôpitaux alors je me
dis mais si le service public lui-même
déroge à son devoir à son obligation
légale juridique de respecter la laïcité
les associations elles sur qui prendrai
l'exemple
donc je pense que je pense qu'il faut
mettre l'argent là où il faut il veut le
mettre dans le service public
il faut être absolument intransigeant
sur ce rush sur l'application de la
laïcité par le service public revenir un
peu sur notre histoire et voir quand est
ce que la boîte de pandore a été ouverte
est ce qu'elle a été ouverte avec la loi
debré qui a permis à l'argent public de
financer les écoles privées
confessionnelles
aujourd'hui je pense que nous payons
aussi les les frais de cette de cette
décision là mais toutes les entorses qui
ont été faites à la laïcité les unes
après les autres ont fait qu'aujourd'hui
cette valeur a été affaiblie et que bien
entendu
non seulement elle n'est plus respectée
par les associations mais en plus elle
est décriée ce qu'il faut peut-être
rappeler aux ce qui porte à ceux parmi
les musulmans qui porte un discours
hostiles à la laïcité c'est que la
laïcité est ce qui leur permet d'exercer
leur culte librement en france sans être
contrainte de payer une dîme à l'état
catholique pour pouvoir construire des
mosquées ou observer le culte musulman
en france donc la laïcité est faite
aussi pour le culte musulman etc et
toutes les toutes les attaques contre
elle me rappelle curieusement ce qui a
été fait justement au moment de la
naissance de la confrérie des frères
musulmans en egypte lorsque la valeur la
valeur phare que la société que les les
personnes que les esprits éclairés dans
la société égyptienne à l'époque essaie
de promouvoir s'appelait la démocratie
et bien il y avait cette même stratégie
de subversion de la part des frères
musulmans contre la démocratie en disant
que la démocratie était de couvrir que
c'était une hérésie puisque c'était la
volonté des hommes et que seule la
volonté dans la prime jusqu'à ce que
taqiya oblige maintenant les islamistes
nous explique ce sont finalement eux les
plus grands démocrates
nous commençons à en voir les prémices
en france le détournement du sens même
de la laïcité puisque nous avons des
islamiste notoire qui nous parle de la
laïcité de ses bienfaits la laïcité
d'ailleurs selon eux ne seraient que la
possibilité de porter le voile partout
c'est la lecture qu'ils font de la
laïcité c'est pour ça que nous devons
faire preuve de la plus grande vigilance
car l'une des caractéristiques
sémantique majeur de l'idéologie
islamiste c'est cette capacité cette
faculté à inverser à pervertir toutes
les valeurs que ce soit celle de la
démocratie celle des droits de l'homme
même des mêmes des notions antagonistes
avec l'islamisme comme le féminisme on
peut être récupéré
récupéré par l'idéologie islamiste donc
non laïcité laïcité tout simplement il
suffit d'ouvrir les yeux et de se rendre
compte que les les français censés être
de confession musulmane comme moi parce
que nous ne savons nous n'avons pas les
moyens juridiques de savoir qui est
musulman qui ne l'est pas je pars du
principe que musulmane toute personne
qui se définit comme tel mais paraît que
des gens comme moi en france et nous
sommes très nombreux nous sommes vus et
considéré malgré nous comme des
musulmans pas les par les musulmans et
notre droit de vivre à la française est
remis en question
nous n'avons pas le droit de critiquer
la foi de nos ancêtres nous n'avons pas
le droit de deux mois du vin à midi
si on est dans un quartier où il ya un
peu trop de d'islamistes nous n'avons
pas le droit de déposer quelqu'un de
confession juive ou de vivre en
concubinage ou d'être homosexuel ce sont
des atteintes graves aux libertés d'une
partie des français
je parle seulement de la partie la plus
vile vulnérables c'est-à-dire ceux qui
ceux qui sont les traîtres à la
communauté comme comme on nous appelle
mais ça touche aussi des gens qui ne
sont qu ils ne sont pas censés être
concerné par l'islam
les exemples des violations des libertés
des attentes et des débordements de
l'islamisme sur les libertés des
français se multiplient et nous indique
de façon très très clair c'est vraiment
le mammouth au milieu de la pièce il y a
un problème il y a un problème qui n'est
pas qu'un problème avec la laïcité il y
a il ya une offensive carrément sur la
laïcité mais pas seulement une offensive
sur les valeurs françaises si c'était
une audition de sinai bay el rhazoui
journaliste et militante contre
l'islamisme radical et devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
radicalisation
elle a évoqué la place croissante de
l'organisation des frères musulmans dans
la société française elle même dit que
les frères musulmans étaient aux portes
du pouvoir et en même temps elle
s'oppose à l'idée d'un islam de france
et à ce que l'état organise la pratique
du culte musulman
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir tous
nos programmes
autre site internet publicsenat.fr très
bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]